(bright, bouncy music)
- [Voiceover] Graham crackers.
Often best when paired
with melted marshmallows
and chocolate.
But it didn't start out as a sugary snack.
Originally, they tasted like cardboard,
and they were intended
to curb your sex drive.
It all started with Sylvester Graham,
a nineteenth century
minister who believed that
alcohol, meat and fatty foods led
to greed, lust and sexual urges.
And, well, that had to be stopped.
Graham's cure was simple.
He preached that bland foods
would curb sexual appetite,
and he developed a cracker
made of unbleached flour,
wheat germ, bran and
definitely no sugar.
Voila, the graham cracker was born.
Graham's theory, and his crackers, gained
a cult-like following.
His loyal devotees called
themselves Grahamites.
But as time wore on, Graham's
theories tipped the scale
of extremism and eventually
he lost his popularity.
He died in 1851 and that's
when the graham cracker
began to change.
Over time it went through
many modifications,
until the National Biscuit
Company, now known as Nabisco,
came around and successfully
sweetened the bland cracker
with some honey, and sometimes
cinnamon, and chocolate.
However you choose to
eat your graham cracker,
don't leave out the marshmallow.
(light musical flourish)